all right let's talk about this story
coming out of Alabama which is the
fascinating story on at face-value it
throws me the hell off
I really don't quite so what let me just
give you the headline first the church
can start its own police force in
Alabama according to the Alabama Senate
so there's a very large Church a
Presbyterian Church that has over 4,000
members they have a school and they said
in light of the the different killings
at churches and the killings at schools
they feel more comfortable if their
security force can be their private
security workforce could be replaced by
Church Police Officers app actual
deputized authorized by the state police
officers who can carry guns arrest
people the full gambit they would have
complete jurisdiction within those
church grounds right within those church
grounds now first value I mean there's
like a 100 different things that we
could say that's extremely wrong with
this right but but as I read the article
it's more closely compared to college
campus police and how you have your
actual police from the city that work
specifically on that campus now I see at
least a dozen ways this could go
sideways very badly and very quickly but
if you compare it to campus police does
that take off some of the for you I
don't think it's too out there of an
idea like I went to a private university
for example and they had a private
police department they oftentimes
weren't respected as much maybe as some
of the city cops here because people
thought well you're the private police
and even though they were trained by the
State Police and they had full
jurisdiction no one really respected
their authority as much I could see the
same thing happening with these churches
too yeah because there's certain actions
that you may have to take and this is
actually cited in the NPR article that I
read about it there's certain actions
the police officers are gonna take that
if you're actual police officer you are
less culpable for they give you more
leeway there's there's a there's a
there's tears to appropriate responses
that are that are given and benefit
police officers that are not given to
private security officers basically
let's cut to the chase
if a police officer
has to shoot somebody or use deadly
force there's more there's more leeway
given to police officers than private
security firms and I and I think this is
probably one of the biggest advantages
that they were having this however with
the stories that we just covered with
police brutality this is just another
way that this can really go sideways and
also a private police force within a
church setting is not going to have the
resources to do the same thing that the
city can so you can maybe arrest someone
and detain them until the city cops show
up yeah but it's not like they can put
them in their own jails and try them in
their own court systems yeah and so what
this isn't and I'm gonna I'm going to be
fair you know what this is not is this
is not the marriage between church and
state right it is it's really it's
really stretching these universities
that the university paradigm and
including churches III do have a lot of
misgivings about it because of what it
implies but I'm not sure if they're more
than just misgivings and and not really
interpreting the story right
unfortunately we may have to see how it
plays out to see if my misgivings are
accurate and I think a lot of this has
to do with the Dylan roof shooting for
example a couple years ago in South
Carolina where I think a 19 year old kid
went in and shot 999 kill be killed nine
people yeah so obviously people are
going to have a visceral reaction to
that they're going to want to do
something about that I come from a
church background so I I get it I you
know I I've seen University police
officers I get it
but it's still you know it just really
sit well with me I'd like to see how
this plays out and see how they're
actually utilized especially cuz you
think of a church is a peaceful setting
where people can worship and even if
there's a police force in the background
that's not getting in the way of that
people are going to be on edge a little
bit more yeah I guess for me it's less
about it's less about the safety issue I
totally get it from a safety issue the
part that that's uncomfortable to me is
having a police force that's mobilized
around a religion that's that's
uncomfortable simply just because of
history right right history tells me
that usually doesn't play out well
anyone that has the religious
fundamentalism as their guide and also
have
the force of weapons behind them I don't
for a second really believe that this is
how it's going to play out but that's
just an assumption and and we really
won't know until it actually plays
itself out ICC it does seem to violate
the Johnson amendment which in turn
churches don't have to pay taxes federal
taxes but they're also supposed to in
exchange for that not speak on political
issues right which they they break that
rule they will endorse candidates again
we'd have to see how it plays out I mean
the headline itself is enough to make
you spin but again it may end up being
like college campus police but we won't
know until it plays out and we'll see if
my misgivings have any merit